Michael Goe, the conservative politician who last week
announced Britain's new counter extremism policy,
is an admirer of the revolutionary Italian Marxist philosopher
Antonio Gramschi. One phrase attributed to Grammshe,
particularly in Trance's gove this
is his well known aphorism
about the need for a low march through the institutions.
Gramshy meant that political victories were not enough.
He believed that the left would only affect lasting change
by challenging the institutional dominance
through which, so he maintained,
the bourgeoisie maintained par in capitalist societies.
Gramschy, who died aged 46 in a Rome clinic
after a spell in one of the Italian fascist leader
Benito Mussolini's prisons,
called this form of domination cultural hegemony.
Gove and his allies on the near conservative right of the Tory party
have adapted this idea and turned it on its head.
They became convinced that
while it is quite easy
for the Conservative Party to win a general election,
it could not transform Britain
because civil society had been captured by the left.
According to the Daily Telegraph columnist Janet Daly,
writing in 2,014, the conservative government
was faced with a war of institutionally embedded,
mutually supportive ideological enemies,
snuggly and sconched in virtually every arm of the country's social,
educational and cultural apparatus.
As a result, for daily,
the conservatives were forced into
an apparent war of political patronage.
Let me translate public appointments,
she thinks
should be chosen according to party loyalty rather than merit.
This mission explains much that has happened
since The war on the civil service and partiality,
BBC independence, the assault on the National Health Service
and even attacks on the rule of law.
But it is also involved a sustained attack on one British minority,
British Muslims.
Gove last week presented a list of civil society groups
which now faced ostracism from British public life
as a defence of British democracy against hostile institutions.
In fact, Gove was doing the exact opposite.
Gove is turning British Muslims
that use Margaret Thatcher's dreadful phrase about the coal miners
into an enemy within. Gove's project to demonize Muslims is not new.
His ideas were set out in his hugely influential book Celsius 7 7,
published when Gove was a fresh faced MP in 2,006.
Gove distinguished Islam from what he called Islamism,
asserting that the latter was a form of totalitarianism
hostile to western Liberal values.
Gove claimed that a sizable minority of the British Muslim population
held rejectionist Islamist views,
which he claimed presented a threat comparable to Nazism or communism.
Ghost knowledge of Islamist history and theology was then and remains
negligible. He was relying on the work of the Orientalist Bernard Lewis,
the inventor of the clash of civilizations thesis,
according to which western civilization and Islam are at war.
Like Gove, Lewis was an ardent supporter of the Iraq invasion.
I haven't got nearly enough space here
to set out the many egregious errors of fact and judgement
contained in Celsius 7 7. Those wishing to Do so
should read the greatest story
in William Dow Rimples Contemporary Review.
The historian of India who knows Middle East well
called Goebbes book a confused epic of simplistic incomprehension,
riddled with more factual errors and misconceptions
and any other text I have come across
in some two decades of reviewing books on this subject.
Ignorant and bigoted though he is,
Gove has played a defining role
in shaping British government policy towards Muslims.
As education secretary,
Gove promoted a state sanctioned attack on a vulnerable
Muslim community in inner city Birmingham,
destroying the careers of many Birmingham teachers
as well as wrecking the education prospects
of thousands of largely Muslim children.
This was the discredited and disgraceful Trojan Horse Affair of 2,014,
a fabricated story based on a fake letter
that British Islamists were plotting to take over Birmingham schools.
Gove, as always,
was aided and abetted by the Islamophobic British press.
In a separate part of government,
another case study in gramsian institutional capture was underway.
The conservatives
have long been suspicious of the Equality and Human Rights Commission.
The EHRC, whose task was to protect minority groups from oppression
and to articulate Britain's post war vision,
were generous and open multicultural society.
As such,
it was crucial for the Protection of the rights of British Muslims.
The conservative government,
needless to say, set about wrecking it.
Funding was slashed while,
as I documented at the time,
the AHRC has failed to stand up for British Muslim communities.
Under attack it remains a mystery
why the EHRC has failed to investigate allegations of Islamophobia
in the Conservative Party,
despite widespread authenticated evidence from reputable sources.
Anti Muslim prejudice stretching from party activists and councillors
to MPs and cabinet ministers until the very top of the party.
At the same time,
the Shorecross review of Britain's Prevent counter extremism program
has had massive consequences,
shifting the focus of counter extremism policy
towards so called Islamist radicalization
and away from the extreme far right.
Explaining the new focus in the Commons,
then home secretary
Sue Weller Braverman praised the far right polemicist
Douglas Murray for his open quotes, mainstream,
insightful and perfectly decent political views.
Bravo Man added that in no way was Mari an extremist.
The main streaming of Mari
illustrates a central feature of the new definition of extremism
individuals on what used to be regarded as a far right have been
quotes normalized, while previously accepted
Muslim organizations risk being cut off from the public sphere.
To help the process along,
the conservative government
has made a long series of partisan appointments
the key public roles.
One significant example was the choice of William Shaw Cross
to carry out the review of Prevent.
Shaw Cross did not enter this contested and delicate area
as an impartial observer. As with Murray Joe Cross,
his views on Islam would be regarded by many observers as extreme.
In January 2,012,
he told an American audience Europe and Islam is one of The greatest,
most terrifying problems of our future.
I think all European countries have vastly,
very quickly going Islamic populations.
Meanwhile, the individual task
with overseeing the government's implementation of
Shorecross's report is Robin Simcox,
Britain's commissioner for countering extremism.
Until recently, it would have been axiomatic
that a British government would choose a figure
who could be widely accepted as impartial and fair minded
on the question of what constitutes extremism.
All the more so given that the commission for Countering Extremism,
as the part of designate groups as extremist,
it operates without a public charter
and publishes neither it's membership nor the minutes of its meetings.
Many would argue that if Simcox was taking his role seriously,
he should have focused on former Home Secretary Sawell A.
Braverman, who appointed him after she said
Islamists are in charge of Britain now.
Meanwhile, Lee Anderson MP,
a former deputy chairman of the Conservative Party,
recently declared that London Mayor
Sadiq Khan was under the control of Islamists.
Some cocks has not condemned these comments as extremists,
nor has the Conservative MP
Paul Scully
been condemned for repeating the far right conspiracy theory
that parts of London and Birmingham
with no go areas for non Muslims Middle East.
I wrote to Simcox asking whether the cases of Braverman,
Anderson and Scully were being investigated as potentially extremist.
There's been no answer and Simcox has not yet
after the word in public about the Conservative Party's largest donor
making an unambiguously racist comment about The Labour MP
Diane Abbott. So who is extremist?
According to the commission of a countering extremism in October,
Simcox described the popular slogan from the river to the sea,
Palestine will be free as genocidal in nature.
But he strikingly
made no reference to the Liquid Party's official platform,
which declares that between the sea and the Jordan
there will only be Israeli sovereignty.
Simcox has laid himself open to the charge
that he is not a neutral arbiter of extremism.
I should be expected and demanded in such a role,
but rather as a partisan figure
within the landscape
over which he has been appointed to cast scrutiny.
There has been a pattern of such appointments over the past 14 years.
The conservative government has established a cursive architecture
of control and surveillance
over British Muslims while granting legitimacy to what would
traditionally have been regarded as the far right.
There are no signs the Kastama's labour
will seek to reverse the hostile environment for Muslims.
Last week, Middle East,
I asked god
whether he believed that the Tory party had an Islamophobia problem.
No answer. We asked
how he responded to the charge that Tory policies
have turned British Muslims into an enemy within.
No answer.
The silence speaks volumes.